I started building a career at 15 years old,
and here's how I did it.
When I was 14,
I started a blog,
and I soon realized that I needed a better camera
so I could take good pictures to my blog.
I got a camera,
and soon after,
I realized that I prefer taking pictures of people
than I did a flat lace.
So I had a friend who was graduating,
and I convinced her to let me take her senior picture.
I took her senior pictures
and she showed them to her friends,
and one of her friends asked me
if I would take her senior pictures.
At that moment,
I realized this is what I wanna do with my life.
I spent 15 and 16 graduating from high school,
building a portfolio,
doing discounted shoots for people,
and developing a website.
And my parents had paid
for me to take specialized courses in photography.
Since this is what I wanted to do.
I applied all the knowledge that I had gathered
and I started paying for Google ads.
I booked a proposal.
I was shooting lots of couples and families,
and I was enjoying it so much.
I started working as a second judor
for a wedding photographer in my area,
and I got the experience of shooting weddings.
And then I realized I want to do weddings.
At 18, I booked my first
three weddings within a very short time frame.
Then I got married
and Moved my business.
I trained my husband to be my second shooter,
and over the next three years,
we traveled thousands of miles around the US
shooting weddings together.
Finally, it became way too much stress,
and my health just disintegrated.
So I quit about a year and a half ago.
But I gained so much experience,
and I'm so thankful that